[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous
peindre la musique
c'est donner à voir l'invisible
en tant qu'artiste peintre et grand
amoureuse de la musique j'ai cette
fatigue faculté très particulière de
voir de voir la musique en forme et en
couleur alors cette faculté elle m'a été
révélée si l'on peut dire en peignant
devant le paysage et c'est cet
itinéraire là que je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui
nous sommes encore devant le passif de
la neige
n'avez-vous jamais eu une émotion
musicale face à la boutique que nous
offre le monde pour ma part la musique
m'évade mais aussi elle révèle mes
émotions et quand elle révèle mes
émotions je suis en vibration avec ce
monde qui nous entoure et vous avez vous
déjà eu une émotion musicale face à un
paysage ou face à un tableau à une œuvre
d'art
vous qui êtes dans les transports le
paysage défile sous vos yeux l'espace
est en mouvement n'est-il pas là une
notion de musique
j'ai découvert très récemment que George
Gershwin avait écrit Rhapsody in Blue
dans un train entre New York et Boston
très influencé et très inspiré par le
rythme sonore et le balancement des
wagons alors pour ma part j'ai ressenti
la musique des paysages en peignant un
paysage je suis généralement avec tout
mon matériel au creux des vallées ou
devant des montagnes et je peins je
compose je cherche la lumière je cherche
les couleurs je cherche et j'écoute et
j'entends et c'est là au bout d'une
heure une heure et demie et le temps est
très très précieux et très très
important que je perçois la musique ça
veut dire que l'émotion du paysage est
musique je vais vous présenter un
premier exemple de mon travail
c'était il y a très très longtemps
c'était sur les verges de la Seine
du côté de la scène et de du côté du
nord des Yvelines d'ailleurs
je me promenais le matin il avait neigé
c'était l'hiver et le soleil se lève
[Musique]
donc j'ai quatre tableaux ont pour moi
une même émotion vous avez vu
un transfert on est glissé
de la figuration du paysage figuratif à
l'abstraction parce que la musique
n'est-elle pas une abstraction après je
me suis demandé mais les compositeurs
quand ils traversent des contrées quand
il traverse des campagnes quand ils sont
dans des villes intègrent le paysage
dans leur musique donc ça pourrait être
vrai qu'il y a là un lien entre la
musique et le paysage et qu'elle
pourrait être pas
il y a aussi dans et donc j'ai commencé
à partir de là à essayer de développer
ce que je ressentais de la musique et ce
que je ressentais de du paysage et quel
était la couleur des sons et la forme de
la musique et je commençais à en
développer
à langage un langage pour créer ses
partitions colorées puisque c'est comme
si que c'est comme ceci que je les
appelle et donc j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé et ce langage pictural de la
musique comme vous utilisez un langage
je l'ai travaillé j'ai beaucoup étudié
beaucoup fait d'expérience et beaucoup
beaucoup de ratés et puis il y a eu un
grand projet il y a plus de 10 ans
je sais pas si ça vous arrive à vous
quand vous rentrez dans un musée vous
vous arrêtez devant une oeuvre et vous
savez pas ce qui se passe avec cette
oeuvre mais vous êtes attiré par cette
heure et si vous restez un petit peu de
temps toujours le temps qu'il faut
prendre et vous êtes attiré par un coup
de pinceau par la composition par les
harmonies et bien c'est ce va arriver
quand j'ai revisité pour la haine une
fois les 9 Ethan Monet au musée de
lingerie à Paris je me suis dit mais
c'est bien sûr
Monet atteint là des partitions alors
j'ai eu l'autorisation exceptionnelle de
venir peindre devant les nafies de
monnaie pendant 18 mois j'ai pu scruter
la couche picturale j'ai pu scruter
toutes les couleurs qui a mis Monet et
quand je me rends compte qu'il prend son
pinceau et que tous les 10 cm il va
rajouter
un coup de pinceau bleu vers rose jaune
si c'est pas du rythme ça entre les deux
arbres qui sont des mesures il se passe
quelque chose une réflexion et donc j'ai
pu travailler sur les partitions
colorées des Nymphéas et j'en ai fait
plus de 20 mètres linéaires de toile je
vais vous en présenter trois puisque
maintenant je peux vous les présenter en
musique sur la musique de Bach Schubert
ou Chostakovitch
[Musique]
alors ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
c'est de mettre le public entre la
musique et la peinture comme ici lorsque
les nymphéas ont été exposées à laverie
aux États-Unis et de voir que cette
musique elle est matérielle on peut la
construire bon vous avez remarqué que
les cercles chromatiques sont des ondes
de propagation sur des fonds sonores
donc on a vu que la musique elle est
passée de l'émotion à l'abstraction et à
un langage alors il m'a fallu quand même
travailler cette musique en dehors de
tout paysage comme le compositeur
l'écrit sur la portée je vais l'écrire
sur la toile
connaissez-vous la valse de Maurice
Ravel elle a été commandée par diaggiène
à Maurice Ravel en 1906 c'est une très
très belle musique très puissante
puisque Maurice Ravel va l'écrire après
la Première Guerre mondiale donc vous
imaginez tout la destruction du monde y
est intégrée et je vous invite à
l'écouter chez vous elle dure 14 minutes
et il faut aller jusqu'au bout toujours
le temps prendre le temps de d'écouter
une musique alors moi je l'ai découverte
lors des répétitions de l'Orchestre
Philharmonique de Radio France salle
Pleyel j'ai vu l'autorisation de venir
dans la salle vide avec ma petite
aquarelle et donc là je me suis retrouvé
pas avec un deux ou trois musiciens je
me suis retrouvé avec un orchestre
entier avec ses vibrations et toute sa
sonorité qui est explosée de de
l'orchestre donc j'étais un tout petit
peu impressionnée quand même je me suis
dit bon
comment commencer et alors je me suis
dit je vais commencer à travailler sur
la couleur de chacun des instruments
j'aime beaucoup travailler sur le monde
coloré des musiciens je pense qu'ils
sont chacun dans des zones de
propagation colorées différentes et donc
j'ai pu travailler sur un éventail une
palette de couleurs donc vous voyez à
gauche ce sont les violons la harpe en
mauve et puis on va dans les graves les
violons selles et les basses on va faire
les bleus et les maux et au dessus il
est parti
les percussions
alors il avait la couleur des sons mais
il y a aussi la structure de la musique
alors le chef d'orchestre envoie la
musique il explique il met les mots sur
comment la musique peut être construite
il y a des rythmes il y a des sons très
très grave et qui prennent une très très
grande ampleur avec des ondes de
propagation énormes et ça toute cette
musique là elle rentre en vibration en
nous et je la ressort comme ça et donc
après plusieurs études et ses heures
passées ça le Pleyel j'ai pas cette
partition colorée de la valse de Maurice
Ravel
alors c'est une partie c'est une phrase
musicale qui jouait 8 fois par
l'orchestre de plus en plus dramatique
jusqu'à l'agonie du monde vraiment c'est
une musique à écouter
alors ne souhaiteriez-vous pas vous voir
c'est représentations de la musique
c'est grand tableau au dessus des
orchestres
moi je trouve que ce serait un partage
d'émotion absolument incroyable
alors
la musique peut donc se voir
alors c'est de la croix qu'il c'est de
la croix qu'il écrivait déjà en 1856 on
en viendra un jour à exécuter des
symphonies en même temps qu'on
représentera de beaux tableaux pour en
augmenter l'impression je crois que ce
jour est arrivé
alors je vous fais ce cadeau aujourd'hui
vous avez prévu d'aller voir la septième
symphonie de Beethoven vous allez dans
la salle de concert vous y êtes ne
bougez pas les musiciens arrivent
accorde leurs instruments et la chef
d'orchestre rentre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc qu'avons-nous fait pendant
l'organisation de pendant l'organisation
de ces de ces conférences pendant les
écrits j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches
et je m'aperçois quand même que la
musique est abstraction en peinture
depuis un siècle au moins alors je vais
vous présenter d'autres artistes très
très brièvement je vous inviterai
évidemment à lire des choses sur
Internet là dessus
et ces artistes
moi mes maîtres à moi sont sésame
Picasso la Renaissance et plein d'autres
encore mais il y a des peintres qui sont
synestètes des musicalistes on pourrait
les appeler il y a Kandinsky Paul Klee
et coupe car mes trois quarts je vous
présenter un peu leur travail très très
brièvement parce qu'on a pas beaucoup de
temps le temps le temps est précieux
voilà donc en étire en 1909 a fait toute
une série sur sur les paysages où la
puissance de la couleur est déjà et déjà
notable donc il va travailler là une
représentation d'un concert ce concert
le piano vous voyez que la musique
est jaune et envahit tout l'espace il
dit les tons des couleurs comme ceux de
la musique sont du nature beaucoup plus
fine provoquant dans l'âme des
vibrations beaucoup plus subtiles
indescriptible par les mots
je peux vous assurer qu'avec les mots
c'est pas facile et ensuite on va house
il va enseigner le lien qu'il y a entre
la couleur et la forme ils vont écrire
une théorie un tout petit bouquin qu'il
faut absolument lire si vous aussi le
sujet vous intéresse et il était
sinistré musique il voit la couleur
musicalement le bleu clair s'apparente à
la flûte le foncé au violoncelle s'il
fonce encore à la sonorité somptueuse de
la contrebasse dans ces tons les plus
profonds les plus majestueux les Bleus
sont comparables au son grave de l'orgue
le jaune devient facilement aigu et ne
serait devenu très profond
on est en 1925
Paul Klee aussi lui était violoniste et
peintre il a beaucoup travaillé sur les
paysages là je vous montre un paysage
entre figuration et abstraction le
premier plan sont presque des notes qui
sont devant cette montagne bleue il va
beaucoup travailler sur les émotions
qu'il a de l'air de la lumière il va
transformer ça en couleur il sera la
couleur dira-t-il mais aussi il dira je
trouve que c'est très bien pour
aujourd'hui l'art ne reproduit pas le
visible il rend visible et ensuite
toujours dans le bar house il va
enseigner il va créer une nouvelle
écriture musicale dans lequel il va
intégrer la temporalité le temps
toujours le temps et là ça s'appelle une
polyphonie et moi j'y perçois des
espaces en vibration les uns aux autres
qui crient
qui créent des espaces colorés dans la
musique j'ai pas le temps de vous parler
de coupe cas mais je vous invite à
regarder sur internet un très très grand
artiste
alors donnez à voir la musique et est
possible il y a là un potentiel de
création absolument incroyable
et aujourd'hui on est dans une société
de tout à l'image on a des images de
tout surtout trop peut-être mais nous
n'avons aucune image de la musique
comment pourrait-on faire j'espère que
la jeune génération pourra trouver
quelque chose aujourd'hui comment
pourrait-on faire pour proposer à voir
de la musique alors évidemment chacun
d'entre vous peut-être vous êtes posé la
question peut-être avez-vous des
couleurs des paysages chacun d'entre eux
de tous ses peintres même il y a eu un
mouvement musicaliste dans les années 30
on se rend compte qu'il existe quelque
chose que ces propositions sont toutes
différentes mais elle serait elle serait
vraiment vraiment intéressante à voir
pour ma part je cherche j'intègre les
vibrations des paysages intègre les
vibrations de la musique et je lui
transpose je le cherche à structurer
cette musique la musique ce n'est pas
que la couleur de la forme il a la
temporalité il y a l'espace-temps de la
musique il y a
l'arythmique il y a tant de données à
prendre en compte et vous prendriez vous
le temps vous de vivre vos émotions de
vivre les vibrations que vous procure le
monde un paysage ou même une rencontre
quand feriez-vous ce serait magnifique
pour conclure je vous invite ce soir à
Paris maintenant nous sommes dans la
voiture
et nous allons place de la Concorde je
vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis